[La musique]
ne me paie pas assez pour faire les deux, donc en
guise de protestation, je vais juste
vivre de mon travail et nous verrons combien de temps je
peux m'en sortir avec ça.
Je suis à Seattle et Seattle est l'un des
des villes plus chères aux États-Unis
Quand j'ai emménagé ici, je ne pouvais me
permettre qu'un appartement de 100 pieds carrés qui
coûtait environ mille trois cents dollars, c'est
une boîte bienvenue dans mon studio
[Musique]
toute cette situation était en quelque sorte The
Perfect Storm mon  le loyer augmentait de
trois cents dollars
et c'était comme 300 pour ça pour le
petit endroit
c'est à peu près au moment où j'ai découvert que
mon bureau avait un bureau au centre-ville et
c'était ce bel espace mais c'était grand
vide à cause de covid  et euh, c'est à ce moment-là que
j'ai découvert que je
n'avais pas d'évaluation de mes performances, j'ai
découvert que je n'avais pas d'augmentation, j'étais
parfait, nous allons au centre-ville et
c'était aussi un endroit parfait
[Musique] oh, c'est ici
J'ai bien dormi, j'ai
mes tissus parce que je fais des vêtements,
parfois j'ai tous mes livres, le
réfrigérateur était complètement vide alors j'ai
apporté mon repas signature, mon
repas principal qui est du jambon et de l'ananas,
j'ai acheté pour une centaine de dollars
et j'ai tout mis dans le  le réfrigérateur avait un
cuiseur à riz donc je viens d'apporter les
cuiseurs à riz ils avaient déjà du thé ils avaient
du café gratuit tout ce qui est parfait et
le deuxième bâtiment nous avons une douche pour hommes
dans la salle de bain ok nous avons eu
des serviettes et nous avons eu deux douches allez
maintenant je  J'ai pensé à ça bébé
étranger
mardi, c'est devenu viral mercredi,
ils l'ont su mercredi et ils m'ont
contacté jeudi, ils étaient comme
tu sais, tu vis hors du
bureau et pour moi j'étais comme d'accord tu
sais alors je nie nier jusqu'à  vous savez,
jusqu'à ce que nous comprenions ce qui se passe, ils
étaient comme ouais, d'accord, donc de toute façon,
peu importe ce qui est vrai ou faux, nous
avons besoin que vous retiriez vos objets personnels
du bureau euh nous avons besoin que vous supprimiez
les vidéos euh
nous examinerons si ou  non, nous pouvons
vous donner une évaluation des performances ou une mesure pour
voir si vous êtes payé au
taux du marché pour le poste. Il a en quelque sorte expliqué qu'il
était comme si cela nous faisait mal paraître que
nous ayons quelqu'un,
euh, que nous avons la situation et ensuite
nos employés  je pourrais finir par me sentir mal
[Musique]
si je supprimais
eh bien, j'avais déjà commencé à rechercher des
opportunités d'emploi et j'avais déjà
passé des entretiens à différents endroits en
retournant dans une entreprise qui ne me payait pas
assez, ce n'est pas le cas  Je ne me respecte pas assez
pour me donner une évaluation de mes performances lorsque j'en ai
demandé une ou quand je sais quand j'en
attendais une comme c'est courant après un
an et cela m'a été dit lors de la
phase d'entretien
plutôt que de retourner dans une entreprise qui
ne me respecte pas,
je viens d'être expulsé,
cet inconnu, mais j'ai de sacrées options ou
tu connais quelqu'un qui ne
me respecte plus comme avant. C'était plutôt
facile ouais, je veux dire, euh, ça ne fonctionnerait pas dans
la plupart des lieux de travail, mais c'est le cas.
J'espère que vos employés n'auront pas l'impression de
devoir faire des conneries pour économiser de l'argent.
[Musique]
Mon expérience m'a appris qu'en ce qui
concerne ce système que nous avons créé,
il est conçu pour maximiser
les profits de l'investissement.  cela est mis
en place et souvent, surtout à mesure que
les entreprises grandissent, la
partie humaine est minimisée si vous
voulez que quelque chose change dans votre vie,
vous devez faire ce changement parce que
personne d'autre ne le donne, il se soucie de
vous, vous devez faire  ce changement pour
toi